we've got to end on all of the good  vibes with adele's hilarious blooper  reel of the making of her latest music  video now we couldn't stop laughing at  this and thankfully now that could adele  she gets slapped in the face with paper  she struggles to play this this ancient  technology called a cassette tape  anyways  there's more there's more in there too  go easy on her guys we'll see you bye  and  action  wait give me a second  okay yeah i can hear you hello can you  hear me  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Music]  sunglasses  but it was perfect  [Music]  i don't know how long to close my eyes  because i'm driving obviously  we'll do it again it worked it worked